Merci Monsieur. C'est pour moi.
J'ai l'impression d'avoir déjà vu ça.
Pas la note hein, d'avoir déjà vu cette scène.
Et pourtant, promis,
c'est la première fois que je mets
les pieds sur cette terrasse.
Tu es peut-être passé
dans une autre dimension.
Non, je vous rassure, l'impression
d'avoir déjà vécu
une scène est un phénomène
tout à fait courant.
Ça nous arrive à tous.
C'est là-dedans que ça se passe.
Quelle est l'origine
de cette drôle de sensation ?
Comment s'explique-t-elle ?
On se retrouve dans l'atelier.
Je vous explique tout.
Et ça, c'est du jamais vu
sur YouTube.
Le déjà-vu
c'est donc cette sensation d'avoir déjà
vécu une action qui se déroule
à l'instant présent, alors qu'en réalité,
cet événement est totalement inédit.
Les scientifiques appellent ce phénomène
"paramnésie"
"para" pour "à côté"
"mnésie" pour mémoire.
Littéralement "à côté de la mémoire".
Autrefois, les gens voyaient le déjà-vu
comme un fragment de vie antérieure
qui ressurgit dans le présent.
Le phénomène est connu depuis longtemps,
mais jusqu'en 1876, il n'a pas de nom.
C'est le philosophe français Émile Boirac
qui le baptise.
Il propose l'expression
"déjà-vu" dans son livre "L'avenir des sciences psychiques".
Elle convient à tout le monde,
à tel point que les Anglo-Saxons
la reprennent telle
quelle sans la traduire.
Le vin rouge, (accent anglais)
Le tour Eiffel, (accent anglais)
Le déjà-vu, (accent anglais)
Le déjà-vu, déjà vu, vu (accent anglais)
Tu le fais très bien.
Pour autant,
personne n'est encore capable, à l'époque,
d'expliquer ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau en situation de déjà-vu.
C'est
un vrai casse-tête pour les scientifiques.
Ce n'est que bien plus tard,
au XXᵉ siècle,
que l'on finit par comprendre
que ce phénomène est probablement
lié au fonctionnement de la mémoire.
Vous le savez, notre cerveau
est constitué de dizaines de milliards
de neurones qui sont reliés entre eux
et qui forment un réseau.
Ce réseau est comparable
à une carte routière.
On y trouve une multitude de routes:
les circuits neuronaux.
Ceux-ci traversent
et relient différentes aires du cerveau.
Pour qu'un souvenir soit mémorisé,
il doit emprunter un circuit
neuronal qui passe à travers
de nombreuses zones du cerveau.
Tu m'as perdu là !
J'ai déjà oublié le début.
Pas de panique, c'est normal.
Plus un souvenir a de zones à traverser,
plus il y a de chances qu'il soit modifié
ou altéré en cours de route.
Heureusement, notre cerveau a la parade.
Il dispose de divers checkpoints.
Ce sont des zones de contrôle qui servent
à vérifier que tout fonctionne bien.
L'une d'elles est très importante,
c'est l'hippocampe.
L'hippocampe ?
Oui, on l'appelle comme ça
à cause de sa forme.
Elle est proche de celle de
ce petit poisson qui a une tête de cheval.
Cette structure joue un rôle essentiel.
C'est l'un des sièges de la mémoire.
C'est l'endroit où les souvenirs à court
terme sont transformés en souvenirs
à long terme,
qui sont ensuite stockés ailleurs.
L'hippocampe est donc capable
de créer de nouveaux souvenirs,
mais aussi de faire remonter ceux
qui sont déjà stockés.
Il y passe des quantités d'informations,
tellement que parfois ça se bouscule.
Et comme un ordinateur,
l'hippocampe peut bugger.
Tenez, par exemple, il lui arrive
de recevoir un souvenir sans contenu.
Dans ce cas, on parle de souvenir vide.
C'est un peu comme recevoir un courrier
et découvrir
qu'il n'y a rien à l'intérieur.
Absolument.
Et c'est précisément ce phénomène
qui serait à l'origine du sentiment de
déjà vu.
Comme si l'hippocampe considérait
que ce que vous vivez à l'instant T,
les images, les sensations, est un souvenir
alors que ça n'en est pas un.
D'ailleurs, lorsqu'on demande
aux personnes victimes de ce phénomène
de préciser où et quand, ils ont déjà vécu
leur dernier déjà-vu, ils en sont incapables.
Tenez, essayez de vous souvenir du contenu de votre dernier
déjà-vu...
Ça ne me revient pas !
Normal,
puisque ce souvenir n'a jamais existé.
Il est impossible de s'en rappeler.
Bon, si vous ne vous souvenez pas
de cette explication,
il existe une autre hypothèse.
Elle a été mise en lumière en 2016.
Une équipe de chercheurs
a découvert que la sensation de déjà-vu
était peut-être liée au fonctionnement
d'une autre zone impliquée
dans le circuit de la mémoire :
Le cortex frontal.
Le cortex désigne
la couche de neurones
à la surface du cerveau.
Quant au cortex frontal,
il désigne cette zone en rouge située
juste derrière le front.
C'est une zone essentielle
dans la prise de décision
et c'est à ce titre qu'elle serait
impliquée dans la sensation de déjà-vu.
Imaginez, comme moi tout à l'heure
sur la terrasse,
vous pénétrez dans un environnement
inconnu qui vous semble familier.
Vous êtes peut-être victime de ce que l'on
appelle un conflit de mémoire.
Un conflit
entre ce que vous êtes en train de vivre
et ce que vous pensez avoir déjà
vécu.
À cet instant,
votre cortex frontal
serait tout simplement en train
d'analyser votre mémoire
pour prendre une décision.
Est-ce un vrai ou un faux souvenir ?
Je ne sais pas Jamy!
Le déjà-vu serait
donc la notification que votre cerveau
vérifie le bon fonctionnement
de votre mémoire.
Ouf !
J'ai la tête qui chauffe moi!
Si cela vous arrive,
pas de panique,
ce petit bug n'est pas très grave.
Toutefois, chez certaines personnes
souffrant d'épilepsie,
il semble que ce soit un symptôme
assez courant.
L'épilepsie est une affection neurologique
qui se manifeste
par des décharges brusques
d'influx nerveux dans le cerveau.
Or, pour certains patients,
la sensation de déjà-vu
pourrait être annonciatrice d'une crise.
La région responsable
de cette sensation chez les épileptiques,
serait la région rhinale, située
juste sous l'hippocampe.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
qui, je l'espère,
restera bien gravée dans votre mémoire,
et vérifiez que vous êtes abonnés.
Vous pensez l'être déjà, mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le cas.
À très bientôt,
les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Le déjà-vu, déjà-vu, vu (accent anglais)
Pour autant, personne n'est encore capable.
Je reprends.
On la refait.